[Applaudissements]
tu es la meilleure
combien d qui pour remporter deux
championnats consécutifs pratiquement
aucune
caroline tu est le capitaine depuis
compte sur toi pour mener cette équipe
vers la victoire comptait sur moi cette
année ce drame le clamer
[Musique]
il y a eu un accident
quoi observons une minute de silence en
hommage sans sa joueuse vedette ouest
walèbo vient de subir une autre défaite
comment va l'équipe c'est pas comme l'an
dernier
nous ne sommes plus 10 championne
championne ou pas car oui il serait fier
de vous il nous faut une nouvelle
capitaine charles leur guise les
pourquoi moi tu étais sa meilleure amie
les filles ont confiance en toi j'ai
l'impression de prendre sa place sept
postes revient la dernière chose que
caroline m'a dit c'est que cette année
allait être la nôtre même si on ne
remportait que ça marche ça vaut la
peine d'essayer non
[Musique]
c'est du vol et formant témoin vous
étiez rieuse
pression comment voulez vous gagner si
l'entraînement vous décourage nous
sommes à deux doigts de réaliser sur
tout le monde croyait impossible
vous rappelez quand on jouait pour le
plaisir et c'est de ne pas trop y penser
si vous gagnez les matous tableau ça
vous mènera peut-être en championnat on
doit tout c'est gagné pour carole et ya
combien de match d'un bon il y en a
quatre
est-il indiqué
alors on s'y attendait plus et filles de
welsh par les banques ont recommencé à
gagner
je vous ai dû gagner pour caroline mais
pour leur prouver qu'elle nous manque
nous allons jouer dans la joie
[Applaudissements]
remportera deuxième championnat
consécutif
vous êtes toutes des femmes fortes alors
gagner ce match pour vous même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]